українською з українською мовою слова
будемо від і будь-якого Андріївна гаєва
нашу ніжність змінять до програми свічка
ніж тіла проповідь і духи сова чумна
переродилася а з наук вівцями та статутом
педагогіки колегами намагалася а нас
видос вид роботи в українській школі на
зимової школі та на милими намети мало
впали зону біти ну я орендувала знову
пінів старшому класі та в іншу до
третьому четвертому щоб вони по вертолі
осям і ви краще викинути з його ден ось
темах тебе було сто п'ятсот кого така
пропозиція тупицю бачив мало було ось їм
над літерами і період обоє багата
написано буквар нитки на прийшли доказів мало
там вже я зняла його ден і для того, щоб
шкірою в чепиль виходить з ременя
підготовленості класу
чого співали собі розпаду ляп і цин
зняли на ставку
що тяж по всіх класних чи ми хай
але ж прокоментувала ми зрубали
маншук ільків славникова їхнє знімання
модерні завали та ті, що отримали рогинський
такі слова та кіку малювалася рогинський
школі оптимізм volim te slowly кови
слова та травня монокіні що пропишемо роботу
з лову голими словами його склейки в 4 на
знають методики роботи з ними змушуючи та
типчики їх на згадку такі полум'я
саме старшого класу намагаєтеся на
що ти жебрак термін його наполовину
творить і габарити і животи себе в
шкурі ми зняли нового значення слив cyті
момент столітті ставити дітей у рамки
є ватна схема лікування цими
адже ризиками
буду вати звуків та моделі slim на
пропонуєш чірка на синиць миль за ним
інший клас і гітлер ж матері
словарь і розуміти ми все-таки звук і
літера на те ми поспішаємо класі за вийшов
ще слова ти пустий тату молоко не
пробачиш і
оскільки основне методом школі
аналітико-синтетичної ми не могли
вийти із ситуації щоб зняти звуковий
аналіз
знаєш чи кілька слив для списування
це диктанту і отримали все у морі що
до посадки розфарбовування зашита рук руки
переніс на його я знімаю записку
розділ для формування за мій начальник
дурі ви краще чи тим він краще не було
сні та корінь слова 3 клас
там де і може збирати видно жодного слова
і потім цю форму слова вивчили tab2
простих рішень складно
вивчила в давнину разом 2 раніше ви
дражнить одним словом а ви на тому місці
били по готову схем складаних слив я
кивал вчилися там вона буде старшенька
і ввели з обожнюванням tab малювати троянду
мене терміну
і мірошник предмет ніде і слову з нього
поясненням нас конкретному прикладі
тобто не третинний правило, а конкретний
приклад і додали
у інший клас правила та кібри тріски
упущення на букву з отриманням я клізму
про Юджин і про острів був учені часто
пояснювали записки прописали
що ми його рекомендуємо розвинена смачного
варення
словарь але поза грою театралізації
саме батькові період перший інший клас
та й мучителем горобця каже ти заснув
за морем лаком і заз побережи ними і так
далі 3 клас
ви краще ви міг побуду в тексті помер
кубань осі просять щось дуже важко
та інструкцій та цензура що тому що не
бджоли інфінітив в інструкціях викурю
будується інфінітив вивчив і with me нього
не мали kill paris нижчою його у 4 клас
алла за вийшов з посади рішення за with
me його не їм називай великих харчування
тонік тому що ти на мої знати і
форму слово за потребу у бутові слив
лист на дощ і ви кращого та сухих
класі начебто можуть державні програми
на тому місці до дав йому 3 клас
я не можу часто на ґрунтування а я скажу
тільки таку фразу в 4 просив і більше
води на говоріння на усні мовляв і не з
постріляю чим за дітьми я так ви
значилося що стиль і жанр з і можна
буде це вже здорово її олівін
заснув ним у мозку не дітей ціну вільно
якої позиції камери у вигляді
чіткого структуру Ваня будемо ваш
пописати і лопати вас ложку писати та
світ кубані через те мого дав їм а як
що за all 4 роки про ти його можна
вивчити був у нього вигляд у нього душа вибач
просто з постаріла я за ним безоднею і с
3 клас та у четвертому
буду я засну вигляд карим дитинством вчителя
вже прошу ми не повірити стиль з і для
грошей вона не знає його терміну вона на
нього місті
4 клас повернув і форму і мірошників ж
нашого роду в рудному
адмінку на волосся на сильну радістю
ти булави і краще нам і повернув цьому
що не повна картина ароматики виходити
чи ви краще на тому місці і промені ловив
цю тему і дуже сподіваємося, щоб 5
класі та бізнес змі його не йди та слив у
всіх годинах 9 хв переможець не кури
стоїть часто такими формами, де і слив і
там складні алгоритм то ми будемо просто
5 клас напою пити